well tomorrow marks one year since  governor sysolak declared a state of  emergency and right now republicans in  carson city  are looking to clarify the law that  gives the man or woman who holds that  position  that kind of power assembly bill 93  would require legislative approval  if a state of emergency were to last  more than 15 days  now one of the bill's sponsors says this  is a nonpartisan issue  and is not in response to anything that  the governor has done  we actually place the governor in this  predicament  if you think about it because by the law  that we have  you know it's his job to jump in there  and put out emergency directives  well let's you know so we saw a problem  let's fix it  but it is unlikely the bill will move  forward since democrats have  control of the legislature